but the world is going nuts isn't it
Freddie what are we doing otherwise
leave these bugs alone well I saw all
part of this thing called um workism yes
do you know what that is yes it's the
new dictatorship yes
fascism right it's the kind of fascism
is because it says you will think the
way we think you will talk the way we
talk you will believe what we believe
uh that way lies and we will control you
and we'll go back in history and we'll
go back in history and we'll apply
today's slightly warped Morality In many
cases would apply the rules of today the
woke rules will apply it to if you try
the Bible books in history whether it's
a Bible would survive but the Bible
wouldn't survive Shakespeare wouldn't
survive no Opera would survive